[MUSIC PLAYING]
HENRY FAULKNER: We are going
to welcome now to the stage.
I feel like this is
like a Lakers game.
You guys are going to
run down the gauntlet,
but let's do it maybe, if
we're going to do it that way,
in order.
Of course, let's bring
up first Frank Miller.
[APPLAUSE]
The creator of "The
Dark Knight Returns."
We're going to go in
a different order.
[LAUGHTER]
Tony Patrick, who has just
done "Batman and the Signal."
[APPLAUSE]
We've got Sean Murphy, who has--
Just dropped "Batman,
White Knight."
Frank Miller, the creator
of "Dark Knight Returns."
[APPLAUSE]
Tom King, the current
writer of "Batman."
[APPLAUSE]
And James Tynion IV, the current
writer of "Detective Comics."
[APPLAUSE]
All of you, welcome.
Thank you for coming out.
We are super, super excited.
So I'm going to jump out
and throw some questions
out that are for all of you.
Batman is one of
the most well-known,
well-loved characters in
the world across literature.
And yet, dark, brooding,
tortured, broken, quixotic,
ridiculously wealthy,
basically unrelatable
in almost every
aspect, how do you
account for this popularity
of the character?
FRANK MILLER: I thought
he was a bundle of joy.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY FAULKNER: To write, maybe.
FRANK MILLER: Hey, look,
he's having a good time.
Maybe the crooks
aren't, but he's--
all right.
He ain't so gloomy.
JAMES TYNION IV: Yeah.
FRANK MILLER: He come from
a very dark beginning,
but you don't keep
doing something for that
long because you're depressed.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY FAULKNER: OK.
TOM KING: So it's just me that
keeps doing the depressing?
I get it.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANK MILLER: No.
You just keep doing
what you're doing.
TOM KING: I'd say
what I relate to is
he's sort of a machine for
turning pain into hope.
His superpower, the
one power he has
to stand next to
Batman and Wonder Woman
is that his parents were killed.
Like, that's an odd
superpower to have.
But what makes him
powerful is that the worst
moment in his life, he turns
that moment into strength.
And I think a lot of people,
when they look at their lives,
they sort of come to realize
that the pain and the worst
parts of you become like the
greatest parts of you, that
become sort of what you
rely on in the bad moments.
It's like I've been
through something.
I've been through
something horrible.
Now, I can handle the
horrible that's coming at me.
FRANK MILLER: Like
Friedrich Nietzsche.
TOM KING: Yeah.
Like Friedrich Nietzsche.
HENRY FAULKNER: OK.
TOM KING: Batman has looked into
the abyss as we all have, and--
JAMES TYNION IV: And
the abyss was afraid.
It's the one time
that's happened.
HENRY FAULKNER: And
so that's all right.
That's a take I had
not seen on that.
TOM KING: Nailed it.
HENRY FAULKNER: In terms of--
all right-- a happy and
hopeful Batman, some of that
seems to revolve
around the family.
And each of you has taken
a different approach
to giving Batman
a family of sorts.
How have you come at that?
What does a successful
Bat family look like?
FRANK MILLER: Lots and
lots of pointy ears.
[LAUGHTER]
And lots of Robins,
bags of Robins.
Short shorts.
One Carmine Infantino cover
that I've always wanted to see
but never existed
was to have Batman
on a Batphone in a Batcave
sitting next to the Batmobile,
talking to the Batphone
saying, oh, commissioner, this
is a tough job.
This may cost me
six, seven Robins.
[LAUGHTER]
Once they started killing
one, then they killed another,
around here, it's open season.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY FAULKNER: We don't even
bother with the 900 number
anymore.
JAMES TYNION IV: Oh god.
I mean, I think
one of the things,
his family is into the
entire concept of Batman.
Bruce lost family, and is that's
the sort of the founding trauma
that led him on this path.
So that story ultimately
goes to building family.
That's really the only way
out of where he started.
And it's everything
that you lose when you
experience that kind of trauma.
He can't find through
himself necessarily anymore,
but he can find it through
these other people,
these other sources
of light around him.
I mean, that's been sort of
one of the driving principles.
My "Detective Comics" run
is sort of Batman team book.
Now, there are a
million people who
have been sidekicks to
Batman at different points,
and I just brought a
bunch of my favorites
and stuck them in one book.
Each one sort of taps into a
different core aspect of Bruce
that allows him to kind of
approach the light again,
and that's why you get the
incredible bright-colored
costumes and all
of that compared
to the blacks and greys.
HENRY FAULKNER: Interesting.
Well, on that note, now the
Robins, or the new protegees,
keep increasing.
We have the Signal.
FRANK MILLER: There's a lot
of people with guns out there.
HENRY FAULKNER: Yeah.
Well, that also explains
the bright colors.
FRANK MILLER: You need
a good stock of Robins.
HENRY FAULKNER: Brightly-colored
Robins and plenty of them.
FRANK MILLER: Yeah.
I mean, the Batmobile
is permanently
parked outside the orphanage.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY FAULKNER: Kids
love cars, it's true.
[LAUGHTER]
Getting back to
the newest protege,
so we have the Signal who is
joining this pedigree of sort
of bat-like heroes.
FRANK MILLER: Cannon fodder.
HENRY FAULKNER: Cannon fodder?
FRANK MILLER: Yes.
HENRY FAULKNER: We hope.
FRANK MILLER: He's
on number three.
HENRY FAULKNER: Let's give
him a little time first.
What makes the Signal different?
TONY PATRICK: I mean, this is
a conversation Scott and I had
originally, which
was, what's going
to be the distinction
between Duke Thomas,
let's say, and a Dick Grayson,
or Kate, who's Batwoman?
And I think there's an
opportunity with Duke
since he is, we can say,
a potential metahuman.
We'll just say
potential at the moment.
But since he has these
burgeoning powers, it's kind
of the first time
Batman has a chance
to kind of get in early on the
ground floor on a new hero.
And I think to kind
of go back here, I
think because of the
loss of so many Robins,
I think Batman
has an opportunity
to do it differently
this time and maybe
discovers he needs the
Robins that he already has--
hopefully intact--
but Duke Thomas is--
FRANK MILLER: But what the
heck if they aren't, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
TONY PATRICK: I mean,
you can only have what,
five or 10 disposable
Robins at a time?
I'm not sure.
But I think Duke Thomas
is an opportunity,
and the Signal in
particular is for Batman
to operate in a different
kind of mentorship role.
It's almost like if
Batman had met Superman--
I'm sorry, now I feel
like I'm in middle school,
like Batman and Superman.
This is what we do all day.
HENRY FAULKNER: Oh,
we're going there.
TONY PATRICK: This is
what we do all day.
TOM KING: We're
in the right room.
TONY PATRICK: I know, I know.
But it's almost like
the ground-floor element
of maybe even preventing
another future Rogues Gallery
from emerging, another
set of metahuman
who will destroy Gotham.
If he can mentor
Duke in a way, under
his particular
philosophy, perhaps we'll
see a different Gotham.
HENRY FAULKNER: Here's hoping.
But the Robins that don't
die keep turning out
to be very evil, so--
[LAUGHTER]
TONY PATRICK: Absolutely.
Go Jason Todd.
FRANK MILLER:
Jerry is just fine.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY FAULKNER: In terms of
the you mentioned the darkness,
that Batman's
ultimately happy, it
sort of brings into question,
though, this opposite.
75 years of Batman is also
75 years of the Joker.
And, Sean, your book
just dropped yesterday.
SEAN MURPHY: Yeah.
HENRY FAULKNER: "White Knight."
So we see a not only
rehabilitated Joker,
but a sane and heroic,
inspiring heroic Joker.
SEAN MURPHY: Yeah.
HENRY FAULKNER: And
potentially a more
insane or perceived
insane Batman.
SEAN MURPHY: Yeah.
Like if you took
away the insanity,
then he can be a true genius,
a true Machiavellian enemy.
And he'd be even worse because
his craziness or his imbalance
has handicapped him.
If you took that away, now
he's like a smooth Don Draper.
He gets his record expunged.
He shows it to the cops, just
fudged all the paperwork.
In my version of
Gotham, Joker, it's
never proven that he ever
did anything super bad.
It's a big ask.
FRANK MILLER: Oh, that cotton
candy was really nasty.
SEAN MURPHY: But yeah, that's
kind of where I went with mine.
It's like, how do you do
anything new with the Joker
anymore?
I know a few writers have
tackled a cured Joker before,
but I really wanted
to see it done,
to really follow that all the
way down the road, you know?
HENRY FAULKNER: So you're
saying that within--
if Frank, if I'm hearing,
within Batman's brooding,
vigilante violence is an actual
happiness and a hopefulness--
and you're saying that
within the really psychotic--
SEAN MURPHY: There's a sane man.
HENRY FAULKNER: Not just
a sane man, but a very
in control and respectable.
SEAN MURPHY: Right.
Yeah.
I mean, even though we'd all
love to toss the Joker out
of Gotham, as soon
as he's cured,
he starts creating these
amazing arguments about why
Batman is causing the problem.
We know a lot about
sociology now.
White crime exists.
And we know that punching
back doesn't make sense.
Like in the '40s, that
comic mostly made sense.
But we know now
that doesn't work.
So what would Gotham be
if it was a real city?
JAMES TYNION IV: So I guess
we should retire the police
department altogether?
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY FAULKNER: This
is a great question.
SEAN MURPHY: That's issue 3.
HENRY FAULKNER: As we've come
to know more sociologically,
psychologically,
what challenge does
that create for you as writers?
FRANK MILLER: Excuse
me, excuse me.
You're mistaking whatever
the current trend in thought
is for knowing more.
Sometimes people are
wrong for millennia.
You know, during the
Spanish Inquisition,
they thought they were
doing the right thing.
HENRY FAULKNER: Your
take is that Batman--
we can't stay the
course, he stays.
He will keep throwing fists.
FRANK MILLER: Oh, no.
I was just talking in
response to what he said.
But no, in terms of
what Batman is, is he's
just a wonderful,
very versatile myth.
He can be anything from
Deathwish to Robin Hood.
JAMES TYNION IV: Yeah.
TOM KING: But what
you're saying,
the interesting part
is that yeah, he's a--
I mean, people ask, could
Batman do better for the world
and be less guilt if he
just was a billionaire
and turned it all into charity?
I mean, he probably
could save more people
as a scientist discovering
cures than he could ever
save punching--
FRANK MILLER: Well,
two things about that.
One is he wouldn't do
that because he's--
TOM KING: I thought
he was a myth.
We can do what we want with him.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANK MILLER:
Second is that would
make for one rotten comic.
TOM KING: Oh, see.
That's the one.
It's the second one
that really clicks.
FRANK MILLER: Yeah.
SEAN MURPHY: I think Batman
fixes the educational system,
I don't think I'd
want to draw that.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANK MILLER: They tried
that during the late '70s.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FRANK MILLER: They called
it social relevance.
TONY PATRICK: Interesting.
HENRY FAULKNER: Well,
of all the things
he could be, there are certain
things that he has to be.
He has to be the World's
Greatest Detective.
FRANK MILLER: Yeah.
HENRY FAULKNER: How
hard is it to write--
FRANK MILLER: I think
more than that, he's
got to be the smartest
guy in the room
under any circumstances.
HENRY FAULKNER: But
that means that you all
have to be the smartest
people in the room.
SEAN MURPHY: And we are,
especially in this room.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY FAULKNER: Wow.
SEAN MURPHY: Google slam.
TOM KING: Google slam.
TONY PATRICK: Throw
down the gauntlet.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY FAULKNER: But really,
is there a challenge in it's
got to be foolproof, it's got
to be the World's Greatest
Detective-level
story all the time?
TOM KING: No, because you
are the smartest person,
but you're also the
stupidest person in the room.
You're everybody in the room.
You're unity.
You're the collective
consciousness
of this entire comic book.
FRANK MILLER: Also, he's a rich
and broad-enough character,
so he can perform
different functions.
He's also part terrorist
in that they strike terror
into the hearts of criminals.
His first night out
in "Dark Knight"
is a rampage of terror to
make all the criminals scared.
And it continues
through the series.
And he dresses up
like a giant bat.
This guy isn't around
to reassure anybody.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY FAULKNER: What would
you say for each of you,
what is your fingerprint
on the character?
What is the thing you say,
like, I gave Batman that?
SEAN MURPHY: I gave them a
really high collar like--
[LAUGHTER]
Dracula.
I have this Batmobile, the
exhaust is on the front,
so it's always shooting flames.
And I made Arkham look
like Transylvania Castle.
So Batman's become
like the devil
in the city, sort of
a storytelling line.
I mean, because I draw,
people can actually
see the hard work I do.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM KING: Surrounded by
artists, I'm in trouble here.
SEAN MURPHY: Oh wait, no.
I'm with Frank on this, too.
I forgot that you draw.
TOM KING: You forgot
that Frank Miller draws?
[LAUGHTER]
Smartest guy in
the room, indeed.
HENRY FAULKNER: We have
some books we can give you.
TOM KING: What did
I add to Batman?
FRANK MILLER: Yeah.
TOM KING: Batman's been
around for 78 years.
He's been written
in every medium.
A guy named Frank Miller wrote
the best Batman story ever,
and you can't write
better than that.
SEAN MURPHY: Did
he draw that, too?
[LAUGHTER]
TOM KING: Yeah, but the
collars are really low,
so you wouldn't like it.
HENRY FAULKNER: Very short ears.
SEAN MURPHY: So second-smartest
guy in the room.
TOM KING: So the only thing, you
can't add new ideas to Batman.
What you can add is yourself.
You put yourself into
Batman because that's
the only thing
original you can bring
is sort of your own
consciousness and experience
or whatever.
Yeah.
So what I added to
Batman, I don't know.
He's a little more emo.
He stares out windows sadly.
I think added to Batman, or what
I'm trying to add to Batman,
is happiness and him
trying to be happy.
I mean, I can't make Batman
darker than you made him.
And I can't make him
more of a family man
than you made him, James, or as
high collared as you made him.
That's the one
place I think we can
go with Batman that will
create a lot of conflict
is giving him a little
happiness and seeing
how that mixes with his bitter.
HENRY FAULKNER: All right.
SEAN MURPHY: What about you?
What did you do as
your fingerprint?
TONY PATRICK: I'm working on it.
Book's not out yet.
But a little bit more sunlight.
Since I'm dealing
with daytime Gotham,
I'm giving him a little bit more
Bruce Wayne, a little bit more
R&R during the daytime,
maybe about 15 minutes.
[LAUGHTER]
Coffee breaks, yeah.
SEAN MURPHY: All right.
James?
FRANK MILLER: My turn?
My turn?
OK.
Frederic Wertham, when he wrote
"Seduction of the Innocent,"
proved that comic books were the
source of all juvenile crime.
He claimed that Batman and
Robin had the perfect homosexual
relationship.
I made Robin a girl, so there.
HENRY FAULKNER: Well done.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
JAMES TYNION IV: Well,
I mean, honestly, I
don't feel like I have put my
fingerprint on Batman himself.
I've been focused much
more on his relationship
with existing
characters, ones that
have been playing into the
mythos throughout its history,
and I've tried to sort of hit
iconic moments between him
and each of the characters that
sum up their dynamics in each
of those ways.
And I've been trying to
create a Bruce that says yes.
Like, when they would introduce
a new character coming up
and a new young
vigilante in Gotham,
there are so many
stories of Batman
just saying no
Batman just trying
to shut them down out the gate.
And this is the Batman
who I think is more--
the idea that Batman
is a loner when
Robin showed up just a few years
into the creation of Batman.
Batman has been about
family for the whole time.
So the idea of him, how
do we make this work?
How do I bring these people?
How do I create something
bigger, and can it work?
And is it actually a good
thing, to actually say yes
to all of these young people
at the same time who are trying
to work out their issues?
FRANK MILLER: I say
bring them all in.
JAMES TYNION IV: Yeah
FRANK MILLER: Like 30 Robins.
JAMES TYNION IV: Yeah.
I mean, that's
basically "Detective."
FRANK MILLER: We've got
a major bank robbery
with machine guns being used.
Send me 10 Robins over there.
I'm too busy over here.
JAMES TYNION IV: Yeah.
FRANK MILLER: You know,
one's bound to get through.
JAMES TYNION IV: Yeah.
HENRY FAULKNER: Basically
taking the approach of the 300
and just applying it--
TONY PATRICK: To Robin.
HENRY FAULKNER: I like it.
FRANK MILLER: Cannon fodder.
300 naked Robins.
TOM KING: There we go.
HENRY FAULKNER: It would sell.
[LAUGHTER]
There's a market for everything.
You talked about putting
yourself into the character.
Tom, your background
is in the CIA.
So how has that
influenced your creation?
TOM KING: I mean, it
influences everything I write.
I mean, that's how
I spent my 20s.
If I was to write
about my current life,
I'd just be writing about
a guy who writes Batman.
And Grant Morrison
already did that.
[LAUGHTER]
So yeah.
That sort of experience of
having seen people really
be brave and having seen
people really be afraid
and having been both
of those people,
I can't talk about directly
because it's all I'll
get arrested.
HENRY FAULKNER: Classified?
TOM KING: Yeah.
HENRY FAULKNER: We get that.
TOM KING: I don't want
to do the secrets,
but also the arresting is big.
So I put the emotions
in it, and I sort of
draw from that experience.
I mean, my standard
line is it helps
writing about getting shot
at if you've been shot at.
But I think that's kind of BS.
I probably just say that.
It doesn't help at all.
HENRY FAULKNER: It
does sound cool.
TOM KING: Yeah.
It stinks you can't
write realistic.
Like, Batman's famous thing--
Frank, you did this
better than anyone--
when he's interrogating
someone, is
to dangle them off
a building and then
open his hands up and like, ahh!
And then they just
start confessing.
That doesn't actually work.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANK MILLER: It did
the time I tried it.
TOM KING: So you don't
steal the realism too much.
FRANK MILLER: Oh, hold on.
Hold on.
TOM KING: Are we going
on the roof right now?
FRANK MILLER: No, no.
Not at all.
It's just he just said
the dreaded word, realism.
We're talking about a guy
who dresses up like a bat
and drives in a car
that's 30-feet long,
puts a child in danger every
time he goes out into action.
And we're talking about realism?
TOM KING: But that's
what I'm saying,
Frank, is you've got to
lean away from the realism,
but you can't lean so far
away that it breaks, right?
FRANK MILLER: Absolutely.
Right.
HENRY FAULKNER: But
that's brings up
an interesting point
because you do bring
realism, Frank, into your work.
"Dark Knight" has these
constant, very real
political themes and through
all three installments,
from Reaganism to
nationalism run amok.
"Dark Knight Master
Race" as the last one
is particularly
poignant right now.
So do you come from a
political perspective
when you're writing
these stories,
or is that just what
happens to fall in?
FRANK MILLER: Yeah.
I mean, obviously, there's a
political perspective in life
if you're awake.
But also, when I started the
very first "Dark Knight,"
it just struck me
as odd that comics
were so divorced from
everything else in the world.
And that here we have all
this cartooning talent,
and we're not
using it to do what
cartoonists are most known for,
which is political cartoons.
So to me, it was just
a natural marriage,
and it also gave the
series a Greek chorus--
that is, a way for
the rest of the world
to react to Batman
being out there.
And that's just been a device
that's continued throughout.
HENRY FAULKNER: One
thing we mentioned
backstage, every installment
of "The Dark Knight Returns"
has now happened during a
Republican administration.
Coincidence?
Just that's when the
story came to you?
FRANK MILLER:
Hell, I don't know.
HENRY FAULKNER: As diplomatic
an answer as we could hope for.
FRANK MILLER: No.
It's direct.
It's just I've got no idea.
Do you think that--
I don't know.
HENRY FAULKNER: All right.
FRANK MILLER: You got me, pal.
HENRY FAULKNER: I
want to come back,
Tony, to something you
said earlier about you're
bringing Batman a little
more into the light--
TONY PATRICK: Right.
HENRY FAULKNER: In doing this.
And you said that
it's Gotham by day.
Gotham itself is
as much a character
in the mythos as Robin
or the Joker, and more so
than any other setting--
certainly more than Metropolis.
How has that influenced you?
How have you played with that?
Do you guys think of
that as a character?
TONY PATRICK: It's a
big sandbox to play in,
especially daytime
Gotham because, even now
as we're working on
it, we're figuring out
the distinction between
nighttime Gotham, which
is what mostly we've seen in
the majority of the books,
and then a new
daytime ecosystem.
So is that where new
heroes and new villains
actually test out there
skill sets, plans?
Actually, I imagine that daytime
Gotham is a little bit more
corrupt than nighttime Gotham.
One of the things that
we're investigating
is kind of the systems
that run during daytime.
Also, if we talk,
if we get into--
not to say that we are getting
into politics in Gotham--
but a lot of these corrupt
politicians in Gotham
are working during the daytime.
So there's a lot of
different opportunities
I feel that Gotham
by day gives us.
FRANK MILLER: Does he like a
special costume that he wears?
He'll have his usual camouflage?
TONY PATRICK: Well, Signal does.
Signal, to give you guys if you
don't know who Duke Thomas is--
over the last about
five years, he's
gone from just a teenage kid
who helped Batman out in a jam
to being part of an
autonomous group of Robins.
They lived, most of them, Frank.
FRANK MILLER: [INAUDIBLE]
How many Robins?
TONY PATRICK: Yeah.
That's right.
Sorry, sorry.
Would you like to
talk about it, too?
It was a few years ago--
and this is what got me
invested in Duke Thomas--
I was at New York Comic Con, and
I walked by a table and I saw
Black Robin on a
T-shirt, and I was like--
SEAN MURPHY: Hey, it's
African-American Robin.
TONY PATRICK: It's narrows--
nah.
So I saw the T-shirt, and I
was like, I got to get this.
SEAN MURPHY: Yeah.
TONY PATRICK: And I knew
nothing about Duke Thomas
at that point.
So then I went back and
I read "We Are Robin"
and filled in the gaps
in, and here I am, man.
[LAUGHTER]
Wouldn't be sitting here.
SEAN MURPHY: I'm actually
using him in my book.
TONY PATRICK: Which one?
SEAN MURPHY: Duke Thomas.
TONY PATRICK: Who?
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN MURPHY: In my
book, I use Duke Thomas,
so I have him as some
Marvel character.
TONY PATRICK: Miles Morales?
SEAN MURPHY: Sorry?
TONY PATRICK: Who?
SEAN MURPHY: Oh.
There's a Netflix show.
What's his name?
TONY PATRICK: Luke Cage.
SEAN MURPHY: Luke
Cage, thank you.
TONY PATRICK: Daredevil?
SEAN MURPHY: No, Luke Cage.
Sorry.
Smartest guy in the room.
TONY PATRICK: We don't
know Marvel characters.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN MURPHY: I have him
as kind of Luke Cage guy
who's defending
his neighborhood.
It's like he's in Bed-Sty or
like a rough neighborhood where
Batman and the police don't go.
So he's just sort of taking
matters into his own hands.
So that's sort of what
I am working with.
I don't know how that fits.
Mine's Elseworld, so
it's not even canon.
TONY PATRICK: It's not even--
OK, it's Elseworld.
FRANK MILLER: Someone
said Elseworld?
Do they still do that?
JAMES TYNION IV: No.
They should.
SEAN MURPHY: They don't
stamp it like that.
FRANK MILLER: Oh, Elseworlds.
They made up Elseworlds in
reaction to "Dark Knight"
because they wanted to
say, this didn't happen.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN MURPHY: Didn't you work
so much of it into canon?
TONY PATRICK: Yeah.
FRANK MILLER: Yeah.
SEAN MURPHY: And I'm following
in your footsteps here,
I was like let me just
take Gotham, mess with it.
I'm going to just tear it up.
And whatever you
guys like at the end,
you can just use that,
just like the way
you did with "Dark Knight."
And they thought like, OK.
They were convinced like,
well, worked with Frank.
Maybe this kid can do
something like that, too.
I don't know.
Not that I would ever
expect to fill your shoes,
but I had you as an example
to throw in their face.
You let Frank do it.
FRANK MILLER: No.
The idea is that each
guy at bat kicks things,
kicks the bounds as
far out as possible.
And the next guy can do it.
SEAN MURPHY: I'm
kicking it really hard.
FRANK MILLER: I don't mind
filling anybody's shoes.
HENRY FAULKNER: Well,
in terms of diversity,
you've created a Bat team
that is not just largely,
it's a majority of women.
JAMES TYNION IV: Well, I mean
there is a lot of great--
like Batwoman, the Batwoman that
Greg Rucka created or developed
with JH Williams
was one of, I think,
the best additions to the
mythos in a long time.
But that character had
kind of existed standalone.
She had not really interacted
with the Bat family itself.
There had been little
mentions before that there
is a familial
relationship, so it
was like bringing in Batwoman
as a kind of mirror to Bruce,
as his cousin, as someone
who comes with a more
military background.
And how the two of them
play off of each other
became sort of core to the team.
But honestly, in building
the team, a lot of it
was just me asking to use
my favorite characters
and them saying yes.
HENRY FAULKNER: This
begs the question,
how much freedom do you have
on this iconic character?
How do you decide
like, all right, he's
going to be married now?
That is now literally
the cat's out of the bag.
JAMES TYNION IV:
You start doing it,
and you see when they say no.
FRANK MILLER: The best
bit is to come in when
the sales are really low.
[LAUGHTER]
That's when you get--
HENRY FAULKNER: That's how
we pitch products here.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM KING: Being sales
low is really helpful.
That's why I try to
crash every project
and then raise it back up.
FRANK MILLER: I mean, I got
"Daredevil2 when they were just
getting set to cancel it.
So I got to do
anything I wanted to.
TOM KING: Oh, the best
thing to happen in comics
is you get something
nobody cares about.
FRANK MILLER: Oh, yeah.
You get to knock it
all around the block.
TOM KING: Yeah.
That's the best.
The company and the
editors want a story
that will capture the public.
They don't want you
to be a cover band.
They don't want you to just
be like, OK, here's the hits.
FRANK MILLER: They don't?
TOM KING: I'm going to play
them over and over again.
FRANK MILLER: A lot
of times they do.
TOM KING: No.
FRANK MILLER: But
sometimes, they don't.
If you get a good
editor, they don't.
TOM KING: Yeah.
That's right.
You've got to find
the right editor.
That's 100% true.
It's one of those things where
I think maybe the safe option is
what they want because
that's the easiest way not
to get fired.
But in their heart,
in their dreams,
they want to do
something radical.
They want to be the editor
of "Dark Knight Returns."
They want to be the publisher
who publishes that next thing.
And if you can trick them into
thinking you're doing that,
then you're cool.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's the whole thing
to push a story forward.
But you have to.
I mean, the whole
point in working
with the Batman
character is there
is a core to that character.
There is a core, and you're
responsible to the fans,
you're responsible
to the people who
came before you not
to destroy that core.
And if you do, then your
story loses its stakes.
If I'm writing a Batman that
doesn't mold to that point of,
then I'm just writing
sort of bad fan fiction.
And having written some
bad fan fiction in my life,
I'm not ready to go back to it.
[LAUGHTER]
So as long as you
stick to that core,
you can move that
character forward.
FRANK MILLER: Yeah.
And it's amazing
how well conceived
the best characters are.
There's not much you can really
wreck about Batman unless you
just completely trashed
it and betrayed it.
He's like Superman
or Wonder Woman.
They're are all such good ideas.
TOM KING: Oh, he's so
much better than Superman.
What are you talking about?
Superman is a boring character.
FRANK MILLER: Hey, Superman
is the one I want to do next.
TOM KING: Oh, well, never mind.
SEAN MURPHY: You're lucky.
The sales are low.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know if
that's true actually.
HENRY FAULKNER: Too soon.
FRANK MILLER: Not true.
Superman is not a
boring character.
Just go read some of the stuff
that Siegel and Shuster did.
Never mind Bizzaros.
TOM KING: You don't like
Mort Weisinger going crazy?
But to me, Batman is--
FRANK MILLER: If you're
talking about the stuff
where he could push
planets around,
no, that's not real interesting.
Once Once he got more
powerful than God,
he stopped being a really
interesting character.
But he started out
as a character,
he was a great idea that
begat all the rest of them.
TOM KING: But the problem to me,
it's the motivational problem.
You do a Spider-Man, oh, I
let the guy kill my uncle.
He's has that guilt for
the rest of his life
and you can always go.
Batman, my parents died.
There's just a fundamental flaw.
Superman, that's not there.
There's not that
simple explanation
of why he does what he does.
FRANK MILLER: He's a
mentally-healthy hero.
TOM KING: Yeah, how boring.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANK MILLER: I can't wait.
HENRY FAULKNER: At least
for a little while longer.
SEAN MURPHY: Superman,
mentally-healthy hero.
Frank Miller.
HENRY FAULKNER: All right.
So geeking out a little
bit, Frank, your Daredevil
versus your Batman.
FRANK MILLER: Yeah?
HENRY FAULKNER: Who would win?
FRANK MILLER: Batman.
HENRY FAULKNER: Yeah?
FRANK MILLER: Yeah.
HENRY FAULKNER: No radar, no--
FRANK MILLER: He
beat up Superman.
[LAUGHTER]
HENRY FAULKNER: All right.
Tom, your Batman versus
your Mister Miracle?
TOM KING: Well, Mister
Miracle is not a superhero.
All he does is
escape from things.
It's fairly useless
in a fight unless you
want to escape from the fight.
FRANK MILLER: Would he
escape from the fight?
TOM KING: Yeah.
Batman would have
trouble holding him,
but I think beyond that--
in the who would win,
Batman is always the win.
The only person he loses
against is his writers, right?
We have the power.
FRANK MILLER: Or his heart.
JAMES TYNION IV: Yeah.
FRANK MILLER: Yeah.
JAMES TYNION IV: It's
like the only person
Batman loses against as Batman.
That's really the
only way to do it
because he represents this
core idea of overcoming things,
overcoming the worst things.
So no matter what the
worst thing is you
throw at him, to make it a
Batman story he overcomes it.
FRANK MILLER: My first draft
of the first "Dark Knight"
ended up with him dying in
a hail of police gunfire.
it But that did not become
a usable ending because--
[LAUGHTER]
No.
It didn't work, thematically or
emotionally or anything else.
It wouldn't have
been a good ending.
HENRY FAULKNER:
So what challenges
does that create for you?
I mean, when you know going
in, this is the character that
is undefeatable, that only
Batman can beat Batman,
how do you keep that fresh?
FRANK MILLER: Oh, I think
Batman can die, sure.
Keeping it fresh?
That's why they have to
keep replacing us, I guess.
There's just too much
good stuff to do with him.
TONY PATRICK: I think
that, for me, it was always
trying to find his
greatest weakness,
and for me his greatest
weakness is that extended family
we're talking about.
So I think each
writer probably has
the challenge of
figuring out, what
is your interpretation
of his biggest flaw?
FRANK MILLER: Well, and
these characters that
have been around for so long
are subject to each writer's
interpretation, each
cartoonist's interpretation,
too, because they look different
and they feel different
and they read different.
And that keeps them
going more than anything.
I can't imagine
people just sticking
to one hero for 40 years.
HENRY FAULKNER: Before we--
FRANK MILLER: Brain aneurysm.
HENRY FAULKNER: Get to
audience questions, one more.
Both Sean and Frank, you draw
the works that you're writing.
Does the story
influence your art?
Do you find that it changes?
And for the rest of
you, does the artist
you're working with change
how you tell a story?
FRANK MILLER: In my case, I'd
say yes, yes, yes, and yes.
I adapt my art style to
the story I want to do.
And with switching from "Sin
City" to "300," for instance,
there was a switch to a
much more linear style
because it's going
to be a color book,
but also because color was
such an important factor
in the story.
The red capes were a
big part of the story.
And the Persians were
notoriously wealthy
and flamboyant in their
costumes and such.
So you have to adapt to each
project you're working on
or it becomes boring for you
and therefore the audience.
SEAN MURPHY: I think
the secret weapon
for me is, if I'm writing
and drawing my own stuff--
these guys are A-level writers.
A lot of the things
that they talk about,
I haven't even thought
about that yet.
TOM KING: Damn right.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANK MILLER: He's faking.
TOM KING: I'm faking.
SEAN MURPHY: I can kind
of crank together a plot,
but I can only do one a year.
I have to draw it.
And if there's any holes, I can
try to draw my way out of them.
So a lot of times, when I
work with a different writer,
there's always
miscommunications.
And it does add up.
Hopefully most readers
don't notice it.
But when you're
drawing your own,
you know exactly what the
dialogue is, exactly why
that facial expression works.
And that clean
connection is something,
as much as I love
working with Scott,
it's never going to be 100%.
So my failures as
a writer, I think
I can make up for them by
my connection to myself
being the artist.
I mean, there's stuff
I've done and pages
where Batman, the lights
are out, isn't he impeded?
It's Gotham, so I'm doing
all these crazy things
with the art.
Scott doesn't know how
to write that panel
because you need to visualize
it first and work backwards.
Like Frank can do
that because he
knows that his artist, who is
himself, knows how to do that.
But most writers
just generally don't
think moment-to-moment
storytelling
or using an illustration that
turns into sequential panels.
It's tough.
You need to talk to your
artists to make sure it'll work.
But when you're the
same guy all in one,
you can do that stuff
more effortlessly.
So there.
HENRY FAULKNER: All right.
We have questions
from the mics set up.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks so much for coming today.
SEAN MURPHY: Thanks
for having us.
AUDIENCE: This is a
question, and I've
had it about a lot
of art forms, but I
think it's a
particularly pertinent
to yours and to Batman.
When you sit down to write
something new, something that
has such a long canon,
do you ever have an idea
and say to yourself,
well, I want
to check and see if anyone
else has done that before?
Or are you not
deterred by the concept
of someone else
having tried something
and you just want
to make your own
and give it your shot at it?
Have you ever walked away
from ideas because they
weren't necessarily brand new?
TOM KING: Yeah.
I use this program.
It's called Google.
[LAUGHTER]
No, it's true.
SEAN MURPHY: It's a Google slam?
TOM KING: No, but
it's 100% true.
I'll have an idea, and I'll
be like, this has been done.
FRANK MILLER: Your
check is ready.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM KING: I will
literally use Google,
just to suck up a little bit.
I use Google every
day to check ideas
and to look at the past history.
FRANK MILLER: Your
second check is ready.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM KING: This is Google.
We can do five checks.
[LAUGHTER]
That's what I'm saying.
FRANK MILLER: Is
there anything else
nice you'd like to
say about Google?
[LAUGHTER]
Or would you like to simply
mention its name about five?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TOM KING: Google
the crap out of--
Also, I have two nerds
that are my friends.
They run a podcast called
"Comic Geek Speak."
FRANK MILLER: That was a plug.
TOM KING: A plug for my buddies.
[LAUGHTER]
That's actually
not the name of it.
Anyway, for geeks.
And I use them as a brain trust.
They're bigger nerds than I
am, which is saying something.
FRANK MILLER: Do
they these Google?
[LAUGHTER]
TOM KING: No.
They use Yahoo.
[LAUGHTER]
It's just like blood
comes from head.
So yes.
That's a long nerdy
suck-up answer.
SEAN MURPHY: I use
Google a lot, too.
[LAUGHTER]
TONY PATRICK: Me three.
TOM KING: I got
the checks already.
SEAN MURPHY: All right.
Sorry.
JAMES TYNION IV: I've
got like a full bookshelf
of pretty much every major
Batman story that meant
something to me growing up.
And I spend a lot of time
revisiting those stories.
A lot of it is to
make sure that I'm not
touching on beats from
before, but it's a lot also
me finding the moments
that moved me the most
and, not to recreate
them, but to get
into that mindset of where
I was when I was reading it
and how to express
what I'm feeling now.
I think Tom said earlier that
it's about putting yourself
into it, and that's the thing
that's never been in the comic
before.
It's my perspective.
My Batman is different
than everyone else's Batman
because there are the stories
that matter the most to me.
It's a different constellation
than any of the other writers
up here.
So that Batman, how that
Batman reacts in this scenario,
yeah there might be a
story from 20 years ago
that might touch on
some of the same themes.
And obviously, I want
to be aware of that,
and I don't want to make
it boring for the reader.
If I feel like I'm saying
something with the story
I'm trying to tell, and I'm
bringing these characters in
and using my Batman,
the version of Batman
that I hear in my head when
I write, that is different.
So I don't concern
myself too much with it,
but I am conscious of it.
AUDIENCE: Sort of a follow up on
that to the rest of the people.
So it sounded like
you kind of grew up,
and Batman was always
sort of your favorite part
of the comic universe.
But for everyone else,
is it the same for you?
You were always, that was
your favorite growing up
and you were most drawn to it,
or were you more sort of drawn
to comics generally and you sort
of ended up doing Batman stuff?
FRANK MILLER: I was
big on "Superboy
and the Legion of
Super-Heroes" when I was a kid.
JAMES TYNION IV:
Great characters.
FRANK MILLER: Batman
came a lot later.
TOM KING: Like the Jim Shooter
written by a 13-year-old?
FRANK MILLER: Yeah.
It turns out that I ended
up working for that guy.
JAMES TYNION IV: For me, it
was Batman and the X-Men.
Those were the stories
that I just gravitated to
over and over and
over again, which
is why I'm writing the X-Men
starring the Bat family right
now.
I even just stole
the Danger Room
because Marvel's not using it.
TONY PATRICK: I started
with X-Men first,
and then I was lucky
enough to read--
and Frank's not going
to send me a check--
then I read "Dark
Knight Returns,"
and that kind of was
a game changer for me.
And then Watchmen, also.
And then since then, I just
wanted to write comics.
Milestone, a lot of the
Milestone stuff as well.
So here I am.
SEAN MURPHY: I came from
watching a lot of "Batman,
The Animated Series."
JAMES TYNION IV: Oh, yeah, yeah.
SEAN MURPHY: And I feel the
stuff I don't know about comics
is scary.
I don't know how I got this far.
[LAUGHTER]
And I usually check
with Scott or you
or anybody who will listen.
And I think I have
this great idea,
and Scott will say, yeah,
that's a great idea.
I did last year, or
I'm about to do that,
or I did it years and years ago.
So I just stop talking.
TOM KING: About to do that?
That's a horrible answer.
SEAN MURPHY: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM KING: What a coincidence.
That exact idea is mine.
FRANK MILLER: I'm
about to do that.
Great idea.
I just thought of it.
SEAN MURPHY: But then my
friends, they're like, no no,
you can't get into
comics without reading
them the Milestone stuff.
So that's when they gave me
"Dark Knight" and "Watchmen"
and some Kyle Baker stuff--
all that indie stuff, too--
"Sin City," 1 and 2,
all of them, obviously.
I'll take that check later.
FRANK MILLER: Black and white
comics don't give checks.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN MURPHY: Damn it.
TOM KING: Do you know when
you're writing well as opposed
to when you're--
are there things you're like,
man, this is really rolling
for me and this has problems?
FRANK MILLER: There are times
when I'm sure it's really good,
and it may be terrible,
or it may be really good.
There are times when I think
this isn't really good when
it's certainly not good.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN MURPHY: For me, when
Scott Snyder steals my ideas--
[LAUGHTER]
TONY PATRICK: It's an honor.
JAMES TYNION IV: We
know you hate it.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thanks, guys.
You guys are all great.
GROUP: Thank you.
HENRY FAULKNER: We have one
more quick question we can do.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Hey, guys.
Former DC intern
here, so thank you.
TOM KING: Me, too.
Thank you, man.
We got it, too, here.
AUDIENCE: So it seems like
over the last decade or so,
Batman has become Bruce's
full-time identity or job.
I'd love to hear how you guys
approach writing the Batman
persona and writing
the Bruce Wayne persona
and how you balance that.
TONY PATRICK: I mean, isn't
Bruce Wayne actually the mask?
SEAN MURPHY: Yeah.
FRANK MILLER: Yeah.
TONY PATRICK: That's one
interpretation maybe.
FRANK MILLER: My
feeling was always
that, when Batman retired,
Bruce Wayne started dying.
And Bruce Wayne actually
started steadily
getting younger and healthier
when he put the cowl back on.
So he doesn't feel
comfortable in street clothes,
I don't think.
JAMES TYNION IV: I forget
who described this first--
it may have been Mark
Waid-- but there's
an idea for both
Batman and Superman,
there's a lot of talk
of dual identities,
but it's actually a
three-part system.
There's Batman, the persona he
puts on to frighten criminals
in the street.
And there is Bruce
Wayne, the persona
he puts on to mask the
fact that he's Batman.
And then there is the
strange man in the cave.
There is this figure
in the cave who
is speaking to Alfred,
who is still connected
to that 8-year-old boy, who
is still that 8-year-old boy
that he was before.
But he is driven
to be this thing,
and he's never
going to really be
able to grow up because he
will always be in that moment.
When he succumbs fully
one way or the other,
it doesn't quite work.
So it's like he needs
to stay in touch
with that person
in the cave, which
is why I think that his
relationship with Alfred
is so powerful, why his
relationship with the Robins
is so powerful because they
actually know that person,
and there are very
few people who do.
FRANK MILLER: What
about Bat-Mite?
Where does he fit in?
JAMES TYNION IV: He's
just his biggest fan.
FRANK MILLER: Don't you find it
kind of spooky about how we now
casually refer to the Robins?
JAMES TYNION IV: Oh yeah.
FRANK MILLER: I mean,
how many Robins?
TOM KING: Well,
you added a Robin.
You're not innocent in this.
FRANK MILLER: Yeah,
but I didn't kill her.
TOM KING: Yet.
HENRY FAULKNER: All right.
Well, that's what
we have time for.
Thank you very much.
This has been amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
We have--